hi my name is Wayne Piekarski and I work
as a developer advocate at Google today
I'm going to talk about Android wear and
how you can take advantage of stacking
notifications existing notifications
such as inbox style or those that use
similar summary information can be
easily modified with just a few small
changes to your code this allows you to
show additional information on a
wearable device that's easily glanceable
these notifications will appear as a
stack on the wearable allowing the user
to view and take actions on each one
individually or without having to pull
your phone out of your pocket before we
get started make sure you've viewed the
previous videos introducing development
of Android wear there's more information
and access to the Developer Preview
available from our website here so now
I'm going to work through an example of
a simple messaging system for your pets
so these are my two awesome dogs Mila
and Dylan here and they're going to be
starring in this video so let's save the
dogs are wearing smart collars during
the day which can send notifications to
you on the phone the notifications are
shown together with a total number shown
in the phone's notification area when
you click on the notification this
brings up the application to show all
the details on a wearable it would be
really cool if we could look at each one
separately and perhaps take some
specific action or ignore until later
then there's no need to pull the phone
out of our pocket so in this demo you
can see both the phone and a wearable
emulator running together on the phone a
notification is shown and on the
wearable you can see there's a stack
notification made up from multiple
events you can touch the notification
and it will expand into separate
messages you can touch the specific
notification and then swipe it to the
side to see possible actions and when
you use an action that notification will
be dismissed if it's been specified to
do that in your code you can then take a
similar action on any remaining
notifications and remember this can all
be done while your phone remains in your
pocket by interacting with your wearable
device so let's work through the code
that was used to create this example
firstly this is the code that you would
already be using to create a
notification appearing on your phone one
of the nice things about the Android
wear eye
guys is that it leverage as much of your
existing code now we create a
notification that uses a group key
string this is a global identifier that
Android uses to know which notifications
should be grouped together on the
wearable it can be any string that you
want this is the first notification that
will appear on the wearable you start
off by creating the intent and the
pending intent with whatever result you
want this is exactly the same as you
would do for your existing notifications
you then create the notification with
the specific details of the message in
exactly the same way that you would have
done it with your existing code note
that this notification is never meant to
appear on the phone only on the wearable
and we use the call to set action to
indicate an intent for when an action
icon is touched on the wearable display
you then need to build a notification
for the wearable with a call to set
group which puts it in the group
specified previously with the string
constant this is the second notification
that appears on the wearable the codes
basically the same except the message
text and the action are different and
finally we issue the notifications to
Android so they appear on the phone and
the wearable we issue all three of them
separately with unique ID numbers this
part of the code issues the group
notification appearing on the phone and
would probably already be in your
existing code make sure you use a
notification manager compat instead of
the notification manager from the
framework when you're dealing with
wearable devices and now we can issue
the notifications for the wearable
device and that's it we're done with
this example so you can see how easy it
is to add stack notifications to your
applications most of your code and api
is used remains the same and you can
just add a little bit more to specify
the grouping you can use stacks in any
application that might generate many
notifications that you'd want to group
together so some examples could be an
email client and instant messaging
application and so forth there are so
many other cool possibilities of what
you can do here this is really just the
start of what I've shown you Android
wear is really exciting new technology
that's going to allow all kinds of
really neat applications from developers
just like you so you can find out more
about Android wear and the Developer
Preview by
visiting our website you should also
join our Google+ community and share
your ideas with everyone there I'm Wayne
Piekarski and I'm really looking forward
to seeing what kinds of awesome ideas
you will come up with so thanks for
watching and I'll see you next time